well again to this video for round two
coverage of them Hashim of memoria from
sham kia azerbaijan and yeah as already
done for round one I'm going to do it in
a game of the day format concentrating
on one game and going to detail on that
and it's um this round is a pretty much
a good example why this can be a good
format to cover that because one out of
the three games we had two draws between
kawana and kayaking and mamedyarov and
raja baath and those two draws were
really not very interesting to be honest
karana ki can was a berlin wall where
they pretty quickly traded lots of
pieces and yeah the fight in this end
game really is some about small nuances
that are very tough to to figure out
relief for the commentator um but if we
just look at it from a spectators point
of view that was pretty much nothing
going on in the game and Mahmud Yara for
Java for the theoretical duel in the
semi Slav which also petered out
relatively quickly so let's look at the
game that right before the round
certainly would have been expected to be
the the game of the day sort of a
modern-day classic already between
Magnus Carlsen an Takeru Nakamura let's
see what was happening in this game
Tarzan playing default recording Slav
defense Janna camera as widely is known
has a terribly bad score against Carson
losing eight games winning none and he
even had back in February about two
months ago he had this amazing game
where he had widened the f3 names of
Indian where we had a totally winning
position
in Scotland even lost it at the end yeah
bit of a really tough opponent Gaza for
now camera because is a tough opponent
for every player but for him it's
especially terrible considering the
score okay let's see we have a Slav and
not a very common choice for Nakamura he
plays various openings against e4 also
some let's say more enterprising ones
like the Dutch defense or the King's
Indian but he's going for this
relatively I'm solid choice
Slav Magnus is playing III as he
normally does he goes for this sometimes
called slow Slav with III just been
covering the c4 pawn the main
alternative of course is Knight to c3
but white with III is aiming for a
couple of things at one point of this
move order is that if black intended to
go for the semi Slav with e6 then here
is not a particularly great spots to
play e6 white has more than one
interesting idea the main idea is to set
up with Bishop to d3 b3 and this should
be too you can play various moves orders
maybe maybe b3 is the most interesting
one also employed by by Crom League and
this can lead to a very nice positions
for wild like for example I'm just
putting the general setup on the board
something like that for example might
easily happen with white even going f4
23 Queen h3 that's quite nice and III is
pretty much a move that fights against
six setups and and asked black an
important questions what are you doing
going to do now black as various moves
can play g6 for example or you can play
the maintenance
f-five also done here in the game a very
logical move of course preparing East
six Bishop e7 castles with a very
harmonious setup so um yeah what is why
it's a big idea here yes actually yeah
played III to sort of make his Bishop
one c1 look rather sleep but that's not
the main point we see that after Knight
c3 litem has taken control over a form
and on its head looking at the square
and he prepares the moves that will gain
him the bishop and after a six-night h4
is the idea attacking the bishop and the
bishop has no way really to save itself
Bishop d6 for example is a movement in
the structure White has gained the
bishop am black
in recent times tended to not play six
it's not a bad move but black has
recently very often tried to move a six
which Nakamura now place and that's also
a very sensible line in fact cards as
black as places as well so very popular
and popular way to play yeah what is the
point really a six is a good
multi-purpose move at some awesome
preparing to things if y detects iam
yeah you can play b5 as a response or
you can play rook a7 images the main
move it's a good defensive move on the
Queen side and it gives black of course
some some added flexibility for meeting
9h form here black even can consider to
completely retreat it's not terribly bad
idea because the knight on h4 is looking
totally silly
yeah causal played Bishop e2 quite a
normal move developed
the bishop preparing canceling it's very
important to know too that Bishop d3 is
the problem yeah maybe it's not the most
popular move but it's an important that
white is playing quite often it's very
important to note and to understand what
was following in this game to understand
is that as Bishop three very often is
met by Bishop to g6 black can take on d3
it's not a bad move at all but Bishop g6
recently has gained some popularity and
it's also recommended in the recent book
by Israeli Grandmaster and well-known
Theo Titian Boris a Brook he made him
book on the classical Slav and he also
recommends Bishop g6 as being a bit more
interesting in a way than taking on d3
after the capture we get to the
structure we will see later in the game
so this is what cards played Bishop b2
and it sort of passes the the move to
black asked him black what are you going
to do next I'm going to play six yeah if
is six now white is going to play Knight
age four and this move here has control
over G form so the bishop on a5 now will
be exchanged white will gain the bishop
pan and has something at least to play
for so black normally plays h6 year
which is what Nakamura did now just
taking the time to get this nice retreat
Square for the bishop
yeah and now Costas playing act white
the remarkable move he just plays Bishop
to d3 it looks a bit silly right first
Bishop b2 and then Bishop d3 yeah but it
has an idea a very concrete idea Bishop
g6 now is completely useless as why this
is going to take and attack g6 winning
this and
white is totally winning him so black
cannot retreat now and it's basically
forced now to take on d3 which is
mentioned it's not a terribly bad thing
but it has avoided this Bishop g6 idea
so white basically has traded tempo for
for this for this let's say somewhat
superior setup with the trade on d3
instead of Bishop g6 yeah and the pawn
on h6 is blacks extra move and it's
sometimes questionable if this is really
a helpful move it turns out that quite
often it seems to be a slight weakness
we see what happens next is six castles
and now Bishop to b4 that's very common
setup in this line black is setting up
the idea to just take on c3 the right
moment to gain better control over you
for black also instead of Bishop reform
can play in a somewhat more restrained
manner let's say ninety-seven for
example after which white here or in the
next couple of moves can play you form
and this is also an interesting point
with this h6 move if you consider this
type of structure black would actually
really prefer to have the pawn back on
h7 it's not a big deal but there is
always this kind of idea to maybe
sacrifice on h6 after there has been a
short castle what sometimes plays moves
like let's say I just I just put it on
the board just for argument's sake this
is not maybe maybe III is a silly place
let's say here yeah and just imagine
white playing let's say rook t3 and then
tending to here to smash on h6 black you
really really would like to have the
pawn back on h7 it's much easier to play
you don't need to worry about those
it's not a winning attack or in any way
super fantastic for white but it is a
slight inconvenience to have the pawn on
h6 so a very interesting way to play
okay but Nakamura played as mentioned
Bishop to b4 which is preventing a for
Bishop b2
and now cancels and rook t1 yeah there's
a very nice strengthening and waiting
move and it asks black an important
question do you want to play 97 it looks
like a normal move yeah unfortunately
this isn't the normal move as why it has
the very nice tactical trick Knight
takes d5 which immediately wins the game
it's just winning a pawn funny enough
yeah black if he takes on d2 can it will
have lost the pawn if it takes here what
takes on before and the real point is
Knight takes d5 which is covering before
know what is blunder the piece after
this this is answered by this
intermediate move on as it even
sometimes called in in the English
division Zook German word very nice or
intermediate move white is winning upon
with no problems whatsoever is even
having the better central control so
this is a nice trick black cannot play
Knight to d7 here which is the normal
flex of the move in fact what Nakamura
did is he just traded on c3 also not
uncommon and 97 b3 very normal looking
strengthening move queenie 7 rook to see
one group to c8 and now Queen e2 yeah
the Queen e2 is a good multi-purpose
move it gets the Queen out of the D file
and it introduces some ideas let's save
Queen e1 Bishop before could be
'i'm that wines now has after Queenie -
was played yeah and around here in fact
already around here it is very
interesting to check the next couple of
moves because I believe that during the
next let's say we are moved 15 during
the next six seven eight moves black is
a sort of step by step with each move
being pushed back a little bit and this
is quite remarkable because it it
happens in such a such let's an
innocent-looking way that the white
moves I I don't don't tell don't do much
but somehow is making a making progress
it let's look what what's happening you
played 94 you in this position I can
we're a be should be too and now the
next three moves let's say I think
somewhat maybe not not really they don't
really work well together to be honest
now camera played rook F to the ATM
normal looking but he will proceed with
f5 late and if you want to play a5
really
maybe you should should do it yeah right
here I'm not totally sure about the
merit of this move but I feel if you
intend to play a five why not do it
while the Lucas tell on f6
I'm not saying that this is particularly
great but I don't really see the the big
benefit of having the rook on d8 if you
play a fire from anyway even here
tonight you one to d3 is probably a bit
a bit better for white but if you want
to play a5 probably better better do it
now
I'm not sure though that this is a great
plan I mean we can look at what happened
in the game he played rook d8 now curved
blade Knight to e1 yeah this is this is
of course a good very sensible move he
wants to put the knight on these three
and on d3 the knight is looking at so
many important squares he 5 c5 even
before it might be an option to put the
bishop on before for example and of
course 91 also intends to play f3 at
some point after which there also is the
idea to later
activate the Bishop c3 e 1 g3 yeah this
kind of manoeuvres are just very strong
strategically and tidy one very good
move
the problem for black is I mean you
don't feel like he has done anything
wrong but what exactly is this is blacks
idea now did it do anything good to put
the knight on e4 I mean if you plays it
only for you probably you should play a
5 at some stage but does the 5 really
help I mean I really don't know maybe
black should just stay totally put and
do nothing but this is very difficult to
do um in fact he played Knight to d6
yeah trying to make some sense out of 94
and in a way the knight is not terribly
yeah yeah badly placed there but yeah
this should be three years plate just
setting up this pin and it's somehow it
feels uncomfortable what what should
like do now cannot move this night it is
pinned and what is your plan I mean
Nakamura decided to play a 5 at the end
but after 93 I mean isn't white just
better he controls if I've nicely see
five knives the f-4s controlled the
night is just now very nice on d3 and
it's not really so clear what f5 is
actually doing I mean why didn't really
threaten to play for and isn't this just
mostly weakening with f5 very tough I
mean very tough to to judge this but I
think that white already enjoys a quite
a quite a nice position and black has
one very serious problem he does not
have any concrete plane he just has to
be content with the basically a sit and
wait strategy yeah Knight f6 was played
and now bishop before those little moves
can be so so problematic to meet yeah
what is it actually doing you may thanks
maybe Bishop a5 can be a problem
attacking the rook maybe there is this
Bishop II won g3 idea later there also
could be Queen b2 a3 various ideas
Bishop to before it's just slightly
slightly improving the position and what
is black supposed to do now a plate
Queen to c7 getting out of the pin very
understandable yeah and now the next
move is just yeah simple simple enter
and strong plate Queen to f3
at first it it does not really make much
sense this movement to to be honest if
you look at it what is it doing what is
the Queen doing outside the pawn chain
it has a very concrete idea though if
black is playing and nothing moves
you know let's say King h7 okay then
what takes on d5 and black now has no
really desirable recapture he takes its
just can't loading the pawn and this is
what the Queen on a3 is doing it's
putting some pressure
f-five the problem is that also after C
takes you don't really want to take with
the night I mean this is just from from
a strategic point if you're very
undesirable just look at just for
example this is just one possibility
ever but this is looking very nice with
E for coming which is a very weak
structure yeah this is the threat C
takes d5 and yeah Nakamura not sure what
you should have maybe Knight f7 I mean
maybe this is the tougher defense it is
not looking very nice I mean you don't
really want to play that
but maybe this is tougher than what he
did tip at the end came up with D take C
form and this already I mean looks like
strategical capitulation to me if you
are forced in a way to give up your
Center here something is seriously wrong
already
I mean okay Y just captured 9 f7 and a 4
yeah and TM the simple factors why does
threatening to play a 5 completely
freezing the Queen side and this is
something that black cannot tolerate
really he needs to to prevent that and
went for a 5 at the end to make sure a 4
a 5 from Ryan's not played and a general
problem for bloggers you absolutely in
this position cannot move any porn
without leaving behind serious
weaknesses you cannot play e5 as f5 is
hanging C 6 C 5 okay totally out of the
question and well what exactly are you
going to do after a 5 coming from white
so he only has a 5 or B 670 went for a 5
and then B 6 and this is just just a
very weak structure the problem is that
white is also having this c4 c5 idea
and in fact after queen g3 very simple
very strong black is forced to trade
queens really where where where would
you go with your queen let's say here
you're running right into c5 now once
the Queen leaves the c7 square a5 is not
protected and something like that is
just completely winning yeah he
basically must trade Queens this is what
happened yeah and now you're sitting on
this b6 bond which is just totally weak
yeah and of course there is the threat
of c4 c5 so if black plays and nothing
move
c5 is basically resigned so because you
will lose one of the pawn cm just like
that yeah rook takes it's everything's
good
Knight takes also good so he must react
to the c4 c5 idea and went for rook aid
not much fun but what else is there
yeah I know f3 controlling even more
squares note that the Knights they
absolutely have no nothing to attack in
the position then simply I'm pretty much
useless pieces yeah rook b8 and now just
drew c2 every time in the world just
this this and what are you going to do
with b6 the combined pressure on the
beefer that will come up together with
c5 is basically a yeah forcing black to
do anything here to do something any
plant b5 it looks a bit strange because
it gives up PF this this great square
but it really was a choice between
various things that you don't really
like yeah 95 force of course played a
success now attacked and black has no
real defense here takes and he just
recaptured if white takes on a sick
and there is this somewhat annoying
counter idea u3 is hanging and also Ruby
8 so not really useful just take here
and this is much simpler this is weak
this is weak this is weak
yeah and why does actually also he is
really attacking in the weaknesses I
mean you could argue that let's say g3
is not terribly strong or III as a
weakness but there is absolutely no way
black is attacking them while White's
pieces are just about to take all the
weaknesses east 685 yeah and the rook is
also pointing towards the c6 bond while
here what has everything nicely
protected a3 is protected everything's
working perfectly together
yeah and I can relate 95 here Bishop d2
and e5 at least trying to get rid of the
e6 weakness this was successful but yeah
this still remains weak and this of
course as well yeah we have this
exchange him
yeah note that after Knight takes a form
okay one white will get this back and
there is also the D pawn that after
let's say Knight iam d5 would be very
very strong yeah he went Knight back and
no after rook g6 like has some ideas
trying to sort of yeah who's that this
rook is not perfectly placed but it
didn't really materialize something like
that
now the rook on g4 looks a bit strange
but black really has nothing concrete
that he can do against against this
piece the the big problem is that a5 is
just so terribly weak I mean you always
- yeah she was a piece - to defend the
weak pawn and this is just very passive
like Nakamura I really didn't didn't yes
dentists so long yeah went for for
activity by now just jetting just there
giving up the a5 pawn um
well right here after hoopty 5 it was
very tough to do something else I mean
this is the TechEd twice only 5 and yeah
what is black supposed to do you can
remove it but let's say Luke on the 7th
note that this Bishop is protected by
the night the night is protected by the
pawn everything's working harmoniously
together and this is really one of
accountants um yes period ranks strength
as a service it's got perfect harmony in
his pieces almost almost every game they
work together there is no bad piece that
they are protected yeah this is just
very harmonious you know in some way his
style is somewhat resembling yeah former
world champion vasily smyslov smooth
Slav champion in them in the 50s he was
very well known for having this
harmonious star with no bad pieces and
so on the difference of course that
cause in his spleen a much better
calculator and technician so while Smith
Slav was very much focused on this
positional maneuvering style of chess
Carson is also very much able to play
very sharp positions and can easily
switch gears and some yeah but you very
rarely see him having any disharmony in
his in his sinus camp okay in this game
here he 5 as mentioned was saying and
Nakamura protected it giving up
the the pony on a five for some sort of
activity on the rook but yeah it just
went to five this is just very nice
those two looks they have a look at
those important square and yeah really
black is getting nowhere with this
activity this is actually strong rook to
e1 the idea is to go to a one and then
just push the a pawn after 94 rooks e1
saw this trade black playing okay three
yeah it still white is two pawns up it's
got this very strong knight on e4 and he
will now coordinate his pieces for the
final final attack iam just slowly
improving giving black absolutely no
counter chances this Knight is quite a
set piece it will never never get to any
any grade square yeah this was happening
you know there was this idea of course
so King h3 played King g8 hunter g5
gavel just getting rid of this double
pawn
check-check subjects and after rook g4
Nakamura had seen enough and resigned
yeah white now has a very simple winning
plan he would just go over here and then
push the a pawn black has absolutely
nothing that he can do against it
so on the second win for the world
champion Magnus Carlsen he had started
the tournament with two white games and
his won both of them in very very
convincing fashion I mean
mind those two games like 100 moves and
I don't think he made a single mistake
or anything just amazingly strong um
what I think what I really find
mysterious have been mysterious about
this game is we go back around here look
at this position isn't this totally
harmless looking I mean if you are black
IAM and you play a player don't think
that you playing cars right just imagine
you play a player if it's 100 points
higher than you so let's say you're an
1800 player you play against with black
you play against someone with 1900 yeah
would you be terribly afraid it's black
here like is putting so much pressure on
me and I don't know what to do it looks
totally harmless I mean what exactly is
y doing here and only let's say 6 or 7
moves later black is strategically in
big trouble this is quite remarkable I
really don't I really don't know what
what what exactly went wrong there I
mean maybe the whole idea with with
going for f5 it's not really suitable
this is this is really possible I mean
maybe it's just not called for the
combination of let's say f5 and 90 46 I
mean what I think is pretty clear we
look at this this is already not very
comfortable I mean you haven't gained
much we're there 5 and yeah maybe this
is really mistaken plane but it looked
totally natural to me when I saw some of
that life and I mean well not in
Azerbaijan but in the broadcast and
thinking oh well this looks totally
normal what what else really I mean if I
would have this let's say in a blitz
game or something I can easily imagine
playing 94 and f5 thinking that okay my
last squad Bishop is exchanged it's a
stone ball not a bad structure I mean
not a bad structure but it's a without
the light squared
black shouldn't vary too much but it it
still seems to be the case that even
here those weaknesses on the dark
squares are somewhat of a problem and
this is this is really not great for
black you cannot really push any of your
pawns and white has very good pieces
suddenly the knight is looking at the
critical squares
yeah maybe really the series of moves
the plan 94f 596 it's not really working
together too well but it's still quite
remarkable how quickly and I can record
into into trouble here okay so as
mentioned a very convincing start for
the world champion Council is now a
virtual rating on his kind of life
rating of 2819 if I'm not mistaken or
maybe two thousand eight hundred eighty
nine point something so we're his only
lacking eleven points to break two
thousand nine hundred and if I am not
quite sure I read something that he
would need to score six and a half out
of eight of the remaining game so but I
cannot really believe that I mean I
thought I really would think that
winning four more or three more should
be a should be enough but okay well it's
just only a question of time until he
breaks two thousand nine hundred but I
that we will see this later this year
because the level of play is displays
it's just it's just amazingly higher so
I'm really a really excellent excellent
chance that we are privileged to to
witness um okay well thanks for watching
and I'll be back tomorrow of course with
round three coverage thanks for watching